DAN FELD: Hi.
We're here live at the
Founder World Event at Pier 27
in San Francisco.
With me is Purnima Kochikar,
the Director of App
and Games Business
Development at Google Play.
Hi, Purnima.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Hello.
Very nice to see you.
DAN FELD: Would
you like to tell us
a little bit about your
background and, perhaps,
how did you get to Google?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Well, I
started like most Indians
as a software engineer.
So I think I started
as a developer.
I've always been
passionate about how
technology changes lives.
So just before Google, I was
at Nokia managing the developer
network.
And candidly, Google
found me on Google.
DAN FELD: And when was that?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: It
was three years ago
when Play was just founded.
It was Android
Marketplace before that.
And so at the launch of
Play, Jamie Rosenberg,
who heads all of
Play, reached out.
And the rest is history.
DAN FELD: That's fascinating.
So you got the
privilege actually
to work with Google Play
from the very beginning
and to build the business
from its foundation.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Yes.
I can't think of a more
exciting place to be.
When I joined, it was like a
team of less than five people.
And now we have a
global team supporting
developers in big and small
places around the world.
DAN FELD: So speaking
about developers,
I meet developers almost
every day just like you.
We are both working in
different capacities,
but in the field trying
to work with developers
and have developers.
Many of them are
looking to monetize.
And they're looking to speak and
to get advice and to, perhaps,
get features on Google Play.
So would you have
any guidance how
to build it for success and to
the right way of monetization?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
No, absolutely.
So what we find is that the
people who monetize the best
are the ones who don't
think about monetization.
They spend a lot of time
really thinking about the user
and creating value for
the user and actually
being very, very careful
about when they monetize.
So I think that's number one.
So I always tell people,
think about your user,
think about your value
proposition to the user
and think about the one single
engagement metric around which
you can build your company.
So for example, if you want
people to come back and play
multiple sessions,
then think about how
to have them come
back lots of times.
If you want people to spend
a lot of time in one session,
then you do different things.
So messaging apps,
lots of small sessions.
Media apps, perhaps
longer sessions and so on.
So that's something
we find constantly.
Casual games, lots
of small sessions.
RPG games, large
sessions, so you
have to have a bigger storyline,
larger characters, and so on.
So quality matters.
I would encourage
people to go and look
at the Secrets of App
Success on Google Play.
I think it's being given
out to the founders
here today, which tells you
all the different ways you can
improve the quality of your
app, acquire and retain
good users, et cetera.
Really, really think about
and listen to your users.
Think about reviews.
What the people are saying, and
how you can respond to that.
And we are typically
looking at those signals.
We're looking at, is
this a high quality app?
Are users loving it?
What does the ratings say?
Is there enough
innovation in the app
for that particular category?
Or is that just a me-too app?
And finally, and most
importantly, is it timed right?
Right?
Because sometimes you
might launch something,
and it's drowned in the
noise of something else.
And so, yeah.
I mean, we discover great
hidden gems constantly.
And we're always looking
for the next innovator.
DAN FELD: So quality
matters, but timing is not
less important.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Exactly.
DAN FELD: Would you
differ or perhaps
divert your advice between
early-stage and more mature
companies, startups?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Yeah.
I mean, the early-stage
guys I think
are still trying to
find their bearing.
I would highly recommend--
and this is true for mature
as well, but for
early-stage especially--
to build a very trusted
community of alpha and beta
testers so that
they can have people
who can amplify their words.
Because then people will
go out and talk about it.
So building a community of
people who care about it
I think matters even
more in early-stage.
With the mature guys-- and
when it is a mature company,
metrics matter.
Are they growing
at the right clip?
When you have one install and
you get to a second install,
you still have
100% growth, right?
So as you get bigger, is
the growth continuing?
Are the installs happening?
How does the uninstall look?
Are people still
actively using the app?
It becomes much
more quantitative
about how they should
think about their business.
DAN FELD: I know
that you just came
from upstairs giving a keynote.
What did you discuss?
And what to were the reactions?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Well, I hope
the reaction was positive.
What we discussed is the amazing
ability for founders today
to build global businesses
on platforms like Android.
That you can be two guys
sitting in San Francisco
or in Cameroon, but you have the
world at your fingertips, which
I think was not true
even 10, 15 years ago.
When people decided that
they were going global,
they had new management
teams come in, et cetera.
So it is fascinating that
two guys sitting anywhere
could reach the world.
And I gave some tips about when
you think about this big world,
there's huge opportunity.
But you also have to think
very locally to go global.
So that was the crux
of the conversation.
DAN FELD: I think
it's a key point.
Go locally, even if you know
that you want to go globally.
I think it's very
important advice.
Finally, what was your
impression from Founder World,
both in terms of the
audience, and perhaps
the activities here?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Well, the
excitement is totally palpable.
It always reminds me
why I do what I do.
Because being around
people who are constantly
thinking about
changing the world
is highly infectious
and highly energizing.
So I do want to thank
you and your team
for putting this together
and giving me the opportunity
to be here.
DAN FELD: Thank you very
much for taking the time.
I know that you are very busy.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Well,
thanks for having me.
It was really fun.
DAN FELD: Thank you very much.
And thank you for watching
live from Founder World.
See you at the next segment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]